مرحبًا ، هذه ماريا أبديفا من خاركيف
أوكرانيا اليوم هو الرابع والعشرون من مارس
وأنا في المكان الذي اعتاد أن أكون
تاجر تجزئة لسيارات BMW في خاركيف ، فهو قريب
جدًا من الحدود مع روسيا ، وهذا هو
الموقف الذي هو الآن الأقرب
إلى  المواقع الروسية هم هناك
على بعد وهناك
تحد مستمر يجري هنا في الوقت
الحالي حيث يظهرون أه المواقع الأوكرانية
من أنظمة الصواريخ الرائعة وما
تراه هنا
كان مبنى حديثًا عالي التقنية للغاية تم
بناؤه هنا من قبل الألمان  مقابل المال
الألماني وبيع سيارات BMW
الآن في حالة خراب تمامًا
بسبب القصف المستمر
لأن روسيا تدمر كل شيء ،
لا يهم ما يجب تدميره
سواء كان هناك مستشفى
أو مركز سيارات أو حضانة مدرسية
سيتم تدمير كل شيء لجعل الحياة هنا
مستحيلة